[Música]
bueno Y para hablar de economía Tenemos
aquí preparado ya nuestro compañero
Jorge Hurtado que hoy va a comenzar
hablando de Estados Unidos Jorge
bienvenido a este estudio Muchísimas
gracias Bueno hablamos precisamente de
este proyecto de ley sobre el techo de
la deuda en Estados Unidos que hace unos
minutos fue aprobado en la cámara baja
recientemente suspendería este proyecto
el techo de la deuda hasta el año 2025 y
hería el gasto Federal por los
siguientes dos años lo que significa que
no habría un límite hasta esa fecha
permitiendo al presidente biden esquivar
esta discusión política hasta después de
las elecciones presidenciales en
noviembre del 2024 luego del acuerdo
alcanzado durante el fin de semana y que
tardó semanas en negociarse ahora se
discute pasaría al senado este proyecto
donde podría existir algunos retrasos A
menos que el líder del senado Chuck
Summer y también el líder republicano
con el acuerden aprobar esta legislación
el pacto pone límites a se conoce como
gasto discrecional el dinero que el
congreso asigna cada año para financiar
agencias y programas federales muchos
programas federales de hecho sufrirían
recortes presupuestarios el próximo año
porque no habría Un aumento por la
inflación los republicanos lograron
introducir los requisitos laborales para
recibir ciertos subsidios contra la
pobreza especialmente las ayudas para
alimentos por ejemplo en lugar de
exigirse hasta los 49 años se extenderá
a los 54 años para personas sin hijos
pero el debate se centró sobre todo en
este tema el gasto según la Casa Blanca
el gasto se reduciría en un billón de
dólares con el proyecto y los
republicanos dicen que es el doble de
ese monto varios economistas consultados
aseguran que los topes de gastos
previsto supondrán un golpe económico al
corto plazo para la economía más grande
del mundo que de por sí ya está al borde
de una recesión económica Aunque el
gasto se reduzca en los próximos años
también es poco probable que Estados
Unidos vuelva a tener presupuestos
equilibrados en el corto plazo
Bueno pero de momento Jorge respiran
aliviados los Estados Unidos y la
economía mundial porque no haber llegado
a este acuerdo habría sido quizás
catastrófico para toda la economía y
sobre todo ahora que se acerca y que
Sigue avanzando acortándose el tiempo
para el 5 de junio que es la fecha que
el tesoro brindó como la fecha x cuando
dejarían de pagar sus facturas claro
Bueno pues un paso más cerca Jorge Vamos
a continuar en Estados Unidos porque
aumentaron las ofertas de empleo los
empleadores publicaron diez coma un
millones de vacantes en abril un avance
frente a los 9,7 millones de marzo es la
mayor cifra desde enero que publica el
departamento de trabajo esto es un
reflejo de la resistencia del mercado
laboral estadounidense y una mala
noticia también para la reserva Federal
de ese país que busca contener la
inflación en los últimos 14 meses la Fed
como se conoce al Banco Central
estadounidense ha subido su tipo de
interés de referencia 10 veces buscando
hacer más caro los préstamos y también
las inversiones siguiendo su estrategia
de un aterrizaje suave es decir subir
los tipos de interés lo suficiente para
frenar la contratación el crecimiento
económico y el aumento de los precios
pero con el cuidado de no provocar una
recesión en esa economía por esto la Fed
esperaba que el mercado laboral se
enfriará y así las empresas dejarían de
subir los salarios y Por ende dejarían
de subir también los precios pero este
informe mostró todo lo contrario los
precios al consumo aumentaron un 4,9%
anual en abril con respecto al año
anterior muy por encima del objetivo del
2% interanual que se había fijado la
reserva Federal mientras la tasa del
desempleo se encuentra en un mínimo de
54 años cayó al 3,4% anual bueno Jorge
Pues precisamente de desempleo vamos a
seguir hablando pero no en Estados
Unidos sino en América Latina qué datos
Nos traes bueno según la organización
Internacional del trabajo hoy del
desempleo en América Latina se redujo
tres décimas en 2023 y quedó en 6,7% era
del 8% en 2019 la reducción de la tasa
global es gracias a un millón de
desemple menos en el mundo este año con
respecto al 2022 lo cual se debe a una
resiliencia mayor a la esperada del
mercado laboral de los países de ingreso
alto frente a la recesión económica
según el organismo asegura también que
la economía mundial es afectada por la
inflación crisis de deuda de muchas
economías pese a esto el mercado laboral
global resiste y las cifras de desempleo
bajarán en este año hasta 191 millones
de personas Pues el buen dato de América
Latina hay que destacar que la tasa
media de desempleo en la región es una
de las más altas del mundo solo superada
por el norte de África los estados
árabes Asia central y occidental
Jorge quiero preguntarte una cosa por
asegurarme esta Crónica la has escrito
tú o la ha escrito la Inteligencia
artificial todavía la he hecho yo
esperaba pero por si acaso Y solo por
asegurarme debido a este próximo tema
con el que vamos y es que la primera
ministra de Dinamarca ha hecho un
discurso con Inteligencia artificial Sí
hablamos de
que lo hizo para mostrar la
Revolucionaria tecnología y también sus
riesgos la jefa del gobierno danesa
habló del balance político al término de
la sesión parlamentaria usando el chat
de pipí en un momento en que Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea Busca la forma
de regular y entender a profundidad esta
tecnología escuchamos
lo que acabo de leer aquí no le escrito
yo ni por ningún otro ser humano lo ha
escrito una Inteligencia artificial
chatti aunque no siempre haya dado en el
clavo tanto en los detalles del programa
de trabajo del gobierno como en la
puntuación es a la vez fascinante y
aterrador de lo que es capaz
Jorge Pues muchas gracias por este
repaso económico que has escrito tú y te
doy ya vamos te doy la despedida nos
vemos mañana nosotros de momento vamos a
la pausa perfecto
[Música]